hey leute was glauben als willkommen
beim neuen video ja ich habe euch mal
wieder vor bisschen auf chatroulette
mich zu bewegen ich will auch eigentlich
gar nicht eingeladen ich würde sagen
gefangen direkte anwärter gefällt das
noch um leicht wieder hier ist nett
gepolsterten software und ja natürlich
los geht's hallo hallo german bulgarien
ungarn ein schwarz weiß nicht unbedingt
mal trennten
also ich hätte doch jetzt ja und wie
geht's euch so diack hat geburtstag
echt ja bis zu 16 17
hey warum stehen dabei warum steht dabei
nicht verändert und jetzt erwartest du
was ich an die börse bringen aber nur
ausnahmsweise
genau das machen war ihr gebt mir den
weg mit beatbox okay und ich mache den
oscar das geht doch ganz einfach
okay nicht einfach mal einfach so machen
ihr macht einfach so gemacht einfach so
und jetzt do and say it's okay it's
alright supergroup you baby tonight
kannst du auch zwar nie doch das kriegt
er hin
sonst sehe ich das nicht und einig so
stellt kann ich auch nicht okay 123
immer weiter immer weiter
guck mal im einsatz das ist doch ganz
einfach oder machen irgendwie kann man
noch machen
happy birthday hast du doppelt
seit aber ganz gruselig oder lass mich
raten du bist 11 und hass
was an dass jetzt die ip-adresse ist
public report button working to you das
habe ich dann gemacht einfach weg
einfach gebannt läuft berlin
ich mach doch nicht schlimm ist wie
sobald das war nach dieser zwölfjährige
da oder was weiß ich wie heute aber mit
der hacker was ihr der blogger auch im
report wieder zack weg mit dem warum ich
mir egal denn dann hoffe ich dass jetzt
hier online
hallo ihr seid ihr ja meine mama ich
verstehe das nicht
wie man als jugend ich werde die ganze
vor so zehnjährige beleidigt könnt ihr
das mach dass du uns getroffen also die
ganzen nummern wollte seien hätten sie
von uns bekommen von euch hätte ich nur
mal bekommen
guck mal leute da kriege ich noch mal
ohne dass ich nach nur anfrage also ich
würde mir jetzt eure nummern geben
ja aber eigentlich brauche ich das gar
nicht
er zeigt mir einfach mit dem finger ohne
witz was ist denn kaputt mit den leuten
heutzutage du geh einfach auf dieses 100
x 1 bgb chatroulette ist nein du auch
nicht stellt roland ist ja ok aber auch
die sonne
ich weiß nicht werden warum sie da so
viele zwölfjährige nein ich will dich
nicht an jährigen elektriker
nein nein der hat jetzt kann ich am
shisha gezogen
was ist mit der jugend los was ist los
mit denen der saar aus die neuen lcds
and ihr denn jetzt weil ich nett bin ich
muss sie nicht zensieren nächste kein
bett mehr leute ohne scheiß was jetzt
hier wird man ohne witz dieses am ende
wird das sinnlose zähne die mich
durchgehend beleidigen der eine ein
scheiß ich habe ihn zwar zensiert jetzt
aber der eine shisha in der hand gehabt
so ein ding der sah aus wie neu ohne
scheiß der war höchstens 9
ihr könnt ihr mal und in die kommentare
schreiben was ihr davon haltet diese
ganzen zehnjährigen die da schon rauchen
oder so was ist denn falsch mit dem
anlassen kommentare was ihr sogar von
halten ich lese mir das wenn man durch
tokio heute wenn man chatroulette band
aufgehoben ist dann versuche ich sage
nochmal also wenn ihr bock habt auf das
nächste ausgabe dass man daumen nach
oben da mal gucken ob 7006 gründet
bestimmt groß und in wales 1
wir sehen uns dann am nächsten mittwoch
wahrscheinlich wieder hier oben links
geht es heute mit der letzten folge
hiervon checkers auf jeden fall ab würd
mich freuen ansonsten aber nicht